today i'm here to talk about the past
present and future
of css ngs now my name is max and she
said
if you want to follow me practically
anywhere on the internet i am at
mxsdbr which looks really complicated
but it's really just my name
without vowels still complicated but not
as complicated
so first we got to cover what actually
is css and gs
um i'm the creator of a library called
style components but there's many other
libraries out there that we're going to
get into
to write your css in javascript and this
is an example
of what style components looks like we
define a title react component
that will render an h1 html tag and then
we say which
styles it should have in this case our
h1 tag should have a color of pale valid
grid
and a font size of 24 pixels and then we
can use that react component
like any other react component in our
application and render it in our jsx
under the hood style component goes
ahead and injects that css
into the dom now if you've ever used css
then you know that css has class names
and you need to assign them and then
pass them as an attribute
css and js actually automatically
generates unique class names so compared
to
you know writing a vanilla style sheet
you never have to worry about the style
about the class names they're
automatically generated based on the
contents of the class
so don't blink there's a quick animation
here this is what actually gets injected
into the dom
you have some styles with a random class
name like i said and then an h1 html tag
with that class name applied so this
will like i said render an h1
with uh a color of pale via grid and a
font size
of 24 pixels so far so good now
why would you even do that why would you
write your css in javascript right how
does that make any sense at all
well there's really five reasons i have
personally for doing this
the first one and really the most
important one is confidence
i can add change and delete css
without unexpected consequences
that means i always know what is going
to happen now
of course css is still css and css is
still a language that you have to learn
but it actually gives me a lot of
confidence because i know if i for
example delete acs rule in a component
the only thing that can break is that
specific component
nothing else that's very different to if
you're just writing style sheets whether
using sas or lists or no preprocessor at
all
if you delete a piece of styling there
if you delete a class name
you have no idea what that's going to
affect right you have no idea which
pages that is going to affect because
you don't know whether where the class
name is used but because every
every style here is sort of bound to a
component i actually know exactly what's
going to affect it and i know that only
that piece of code is going to be
affected
that's really nice that is actually huge
for maintenance
because i can actually delete if i
delete a component
because i don't use it anymore because
out of date because i want to just get
rid of it
i automatically delete all of its css
too i never end up
with any dead code at all literally zero
there cannot be that code
because if you delete a component you
automatically delete its css
if you've ever worked in a big front-end
code base
you've probably seen a thing called the
append-only style sheet
where you end up with whether again
whether using a pre-process or not
you you end up with a css file that
people only really add to
but never remove from because they don't
know what they're going to break
right if you don't know what you're
going to break you have to always do it
append only you can only add to what it
already exists but you can never remove
anything because you can never be
entirely sure whether that is used
somewhere right is it used in in the
html somewhere is it using a javascript
somewhere is it
conditionally toggled somewhere you have
no idea with css and js all of that goes
entirely away because like i said the
styles are bound to a specific component
so if i delete a component
i deleted css it's as simple as that in
fact if i don't delete a component but i
stop using it
the css is still not going to be
included because obviously webpack
doesn't even see that component right so
that those styles are gone as well which
is fantastic so
it's really really good for maintenance
and makes it much much easier
it's also great for teamwork because it
avoids these
common frustrations like the append only
stylesheet
it's really nice to work with and
particularly if you have members on your
team that
aren't as familiar with css or that
aren't as
experts in css like if you have backend
engineers contributing to the front end
or if you have junior engineers at all
because you literally cannot have for
example dead code you cannot have class
name overlaps you avoid all of these
sort of common issues
without any problem right and for the
developers it means that they can focus
on
making their writing their styles but
they don't have to worry too much about
breaking anything else which is really
nice
now the next point is one that people
are often confused about css and js
actually has really really fast
performance
and that is because we know which
components you actually render on a page
and only inject their specific styles so
if you have a page that is serviced at
rendered the the thing that will be sent
to the clients to the browser
is an html file with the critical css
with the most minimal css possible
inserted in the html in a style tag
and that's it nothing more and nothing
less critical css out of the box and it
always just
works by default that's very different
if you've ever written
like i said a big front end code base
you know
that getting the critical css for every
page of your app particularly if it's a
dynamic app with many states like most
react apps are
is practically impossible you have to
have a very specific tooling setup that
is very specific to your app
and it's very hard to get right and it
usually breaks pretty frequently
with css and js that is just built in
right that is just the default the
critical css four page and nothing else
which is just
fantastic and then the fifth benefit
that you really get from css and js is
highly dynamic styling you can
adjust any part of your styles based on
any
state any data fetching anything really
really easily and it makes it really
easy to do things like global theming
um and sort of build component libraries
with it
now overall i think why i like css and
js is because it guides me
to the pit of success right it sort of
makes me move in the right direction by
default and it sort of guides me towards
the success now of course
if i write shitty code it's gonna be
shitty code right no matter whether i
use css and js
or preprocessors or vanilla css or
whatever right
shitty code's always going to be you
should decode but this is just at least
guides me in the right direction at
least guides me towards writing good
code
of course you can't write my code for me
obviously because otherwise we'd be out
of a job
but at least it guides me in the right
direction sort of gives me some
guard rails to protect against some
common problems which is really really
nice
so that is sort of why i personally use
css and js it's
let's talk a little bit about where css
ingest is at
at the moment and i this is actually i
made this light like a couple months ago
and this is actually widely out of date
now at the time
60 of react installs also installed a
css ingest library
that is actually widely out of date i
checked last week and it's actually 95
95 of react installs also install a css
interest library which is just
incredible facebook itself uses css and
jsa proprietary solution that they built
for the facebook website the new one
which is just incredible
um so csn.js has really overtaken the
react ecosystem if you've ever touched
any component from npm if you've ever
written react
it's very likely that you have at least
seen or heard of or touched cssgs which
is fantastic
now let's talk about how we actually go
here why do 95
of react installs also install a css and
just library how did that happen
well it already started in november of
2014.
a random programmer from berlin called
olek
built the very first css js library
called gss
and jss was really the first one to
introduce
css and js where you could write css in
your javascript and it would be injected
into the dom and it would just work
beautifully
now jss was actually way ahead of its
time as we're going to see pretty far
and jss even nowadays is a fantastic
library that is well maintained and very
widely used
also in november of 2014 ed vs
christopher trudeau from the react team
at facebook
kicked off the biggest shitstorm on
twitter that had been happening at the
time
because he gave a talk at a small
javascript conference in washington dc
called mason.js
and he talked about how facebook was
already using css ngs
that kicked off the biggest whirlwind of
activity on twitter i'd ever seen up to
that point
everybody was freaking out about
facebook
doing something so completely bonkers
and completely out of the ordinary
everybody was blown away and was
discussing about it and
really calling them idiots to be
completely fair and saying
what kind of trolls they were if you've
ever seen any talk about css and js it's
very likely that you've seen a slide
reference from that talk
that talk really spurred innovation and
spurred the community to
try new things we first got in general
of 2015 radium
which tried to make citizens just happen
as an open source library
by injecting inline styles so it would
actually attach a style attribute to
your html tags
and then put all your css in there now
obviously that has a bunch of downsides
because with inline styles you can't do
things like
media queries hover selectors sudo
elements
anything really that is more complex
than just simple styles so
nowadays we know that that maybe wasn't
the best approach but it was an
important step along the way because we
couldn't have figured it out without
trying it first
so radium while it was a great library
at the time it's probably i would
probably not recommend using it nowadays
and it's
pretty deprecated some people still use
it but only because they've been using
it for five years now and can't really
rewrite all of their code a month later
jackson who's finally enough now my boss
at gatsby
released rebase which really introduced
and popularized this css components api
where you would have a box component
and a flex component and you could write
your css as props on those components so
you'd write background equals and then a
string of for example red
right and so you would have this gsx
with a bunch of props in it that
basically just generated css
and that approach is widely loved and
rebase is still a great library that's
maintained to this day and pretty wide
leads i actually use it myself sometimes
it's fantastic and i would highly
recommend checking it out then in may of
2015
the webpack team and the two folks from
australia released css modules now
css modules sort of gets a star here
because it's not technically css
interest you're not actually
authoring your css mgs you're authoring
it in css files
but it was an important sort of
release because it popularized
outputting unique class names before css
modules
everybody was really excited about
naming conventions and probably
if you're building a front end nowadays
you're probably still excited about
naming conventions right and if
you're using like bim or it css or
whatever
whatever framework for css you want
whatever architecture you want
to give all of your classes unique names
and with success modules that just went
away you could literally
write any class name you want and it
would be automatically assigned to the
right html tags and then unique
similar to what css and js does and
before that that wasn't really a thing
nobody really realized that that was a
good idea and css
modules really took the react world by
storm in 2015 and again
still widely used and still a great
great way to write css
department of 2015 we got csjs a tiny
library that nobody really knew at the
time
that didn't really go anywhere and it's
been since deprecated but it was the
first library that tried to
let you write your css in javascript as
strings with the actual css syntax
up to that point system.js always made
you write your css
as objects you would write javascript
objects and then write your css in there
with like background color in
camel case and then you know colon and
then a string in the javascript
and csjs was sort of an experiment to
see whether
you could actually make people write the
actual css syntax
in javascript in strings now like i said
this was more of an experiment it never
really went anywhere
but it was important because it showed
that that was actually possible to make
happen
in october 2015 khan academy the big
education
company that released aphrodite
aphrodite is a fantastic library
that really was the first to realize
that you could do critical
css extraction it was the first to
realize the important benefit that i
said about performance
where you could only inject the styles
that were actually used and they were
the first to realize that in the first
to make it happen
and again aphrodite is a great library
fantastic library still well maintained
widely used
highly recommend checking it out a
couple months later in june of 2016 we
got fella by robin frishman also from
berlin funnily enough
and fellow really introduced this
concept of your style
being a function of state if you've
ever seen a talk about react or written
the react docs
from like four years ago you'd know that
react sort of coins itself as
your view being a function of state and
fellow introduced the same concept
to your styles you can now actually
dynamically adjust your styles
based on the state of your application
a super important thing that nobody
really realized before that but that was
but that actually turned out to be
really really powerful and again phil
great library still widely used still
maintained highly recommend checking out
in july of 2016 sumo pai uh who also now
works at facebook
um made glamour which
really basically was a css and js
library that had similar apis to all of
the other css and js libraries that have
been announced up to that point
but focused on being really really fast
and there's a very obscure cssom api
called insert
rule you can call css stylesheet.insert
rule and basically bypass the entire dom
to insert the css directly into the css
home which is much much faster than
doing it via the dom
and at the time nobody really knew that
that was the case
and so as soon as sunil showed that that
was so much faster
practically every other css and just
like we copied that implementation
and actually got super got much faster
as a result now here's the really funny
thing remember when at the start i said
that jss was ahead of its time
well gss was using insert rule in
november of 2014
almost two years prior to that and
literally nobody realized nobody
realized that that was a thing
nobody really tried to even figure it
out everybody was just like inserting
stuff into the dome and it was fine
but then glamour came and made that
really popularize that focus on
performance and insert rule and it was
an important step along the way
nowadays the library is unfortunately
deprecated um sumo doesn't really have
time to maintain it anymore and there's
better
better more modern alternatives that
have been maintained
um but it was a really important step
along the way to kick everybody in the
bot and say
hey you should be using insert rule
because it's so much faster than just
doing it via the dawn
in october 2616 pete hunt who was on the
original react team and then founded his
own startup
made jsx style which took the sort of
rebased concept
of having css props uh on your react
components
and went a step further and actually had
like div component and p components
and a components and h1 components and
all these html tags basically add
components
where you could then write css as props
it was kind of similar to rebase but
even a bit more direct where you were
literally writing
html tag components in a way um
again great library that is still
maintained and used to this day highly
recommend checking out
also in october i stood on stage at
reactional in amsterdam
and i announced the first version of
style components and star components
really
invented this kind of
odd i would say api that nobody really
seen before
uh with this sort of like style dot html
tag
syntax that let you write actual css in
your javascript again as strings
and it turns out we didn't
glenn maddon is my co-creator of style
components and was
responsible for a lot of the api but at
the time we just
figured this feels nice to us we'll see
what everybody says and it actually
turns out that
so many people love this api and felt
like it feels great to use
that it's now practically the most
popular css interest library of them all
and very widely used throughout the
audience
throughout the industry sorry not the
audience what am i saying a couple
months later
ryan tau the guy who made csjs the sort
of experiment a couple of years prior
and who works at uber mailed staltron
which was a css and js library
that for the first time ever outputted
atomic class names
so what atomics is this concept where
you have a class name per
css rule right you have a class name for
margin
five pixels you have a class name for
color red you have a class name for all
of these individual
css declarations and then what ends up
happening is that you actually have very
tiny css because
you don't have that many unique css
rules in your throughout your
application right they repeat you have
mini margin 8 pixels for example you
have mainly
color red color red declarations many
background rate declarations and so
actually
by outputting atomic classes the total
size of the css that you have in your
application
stick can stay smaller than if you
inject a class name per component
which is fascinating and actually uber
turned out to be a huge benefit for
performance
not all libraries work that way nowadays
because it's
not always clear-cut whether atomic
classes would be
better for performance or
component-based classes would be better
for performance it's not like an obvious
thing
that you can just say upfront about your
application it varies widely between app
to app
but it's really important and if you
want to try that i highly recommend
checking out styles from which again
uber uses for practically all of their
websites
also in december 2016 the zeit team now
versailles
which is a horrible name by the way no
no offense to to the virtuality my i
love their product but damn that name i
always forget it
site was iconic versailles not so much
anyways
totally besides the point they built
their own css and just library called
style gsx which they included in next
and what they really did was they
lowered the barrier of entry for css and
gs
by creating this api that is basically
just like writing a style tag in html
except you write a style tag in your jsx
code but it's practically the same thing
and so it's much more approachable for
people coming from html but not as much
with not as much javascript experience
because it's pretty much like writing
your css in an html file right you put
it into a style tag you write your class
names in there everything works
perfectly fine
and then style.jsx goes ahead and sort
of uniqueifies the class names and makes
everything work
it's a great library that again is
pretty widely used highly recommend
checking it out
it's really cool in march of 2017 we got
astroturf
which basically
was the first css and js library that
extracted to actual css files which
sounds really odd
because i've been talking about all this
injection stuff but it's really nice for
some use cases if you have multiple apps
trying to use the same css because you
can extract a css file
like you're used to with random class
names and then use that
for your react app but also use it for
your maybe html marketing page you can
use it for any view apps you have
throughout your company the css is more
reusable that way it's actually really
nice because it gives you
many of the same benefits the css and js
does all the other libraries
but then you get a css file like you're
used to which is actually really great
in april of 2017 kenzie dodds at paypal
released cameras which basically took
the style components api
but made it work with objects which is
kind of odd because at the beginning
everybody loves style components because
it didn't make you write objects but
it turns out that actually writing your
css as objects is
can be kind of nice it's a little bit
less approachable because people have to
know javascript and they have to
understand javascript objects and stuff
but it can't be nice for merging styles
it can't be nice for you know
sort of using all of javascript to
adjust them and so glamorous can't
really wanted to use that
the style components api but he also
really wanted to use objects and so he
basically made glamorous which
implemented the style components api
but with object obviously now glamorous
nowadays is uh
deprecated and kent doesn't use it
anymore or maintain it anymore because
style components and all the other
libraries with the same api added
support for objects
but again important step along the way
that really showed that people wanted
some people wanted really wanted to
write their css objects and that that
could be
a benefit that people really liked it
may have 2017 now i put style components
v2 here but the whole point of this
version two release wasn't wasn't
actually styled components it was that
we found this random person down in
africa somewhere
called phi sultan who wrote a css parser
in javascript that was super tiny and
super duper fast
before that everybody kind of hacked
around the whole css parsing thing
but stylist really sort of was a parser
tailor-made for css and json so it was
much smaller
and much faster and style is practically
enabled cssjs to take
off because it made every single library
10 or 100 times more performant than it
was before
highly i mean stylus is just an absolute
marvel of engineering i cannot imagine
why anybody will write a css parser in
javascript that is the most bonkers
thing i've ever heard
and it's amazing that exists and it's
amazing that it works so so well
nowadays practically all css and js
libraries use stylus
asks to choose this parser because it is
so so good
in july of 2017 kaihonbegger and uh i
think mitchell hamilton
released emotion and emotion really came
on the scene and they were like yeah
so we support all of the css and js apis
that you like
but we're like 10 times faster than
everybody else and suddenly all the
other css ingest libraries went oh
[ __ ] they're like 10 times faster than
us
what the hell are we doing wrong why how
are they 10 times faster
and so they really kicked off this still
ongoing performance competition and
without that we would probably still be
pretty slow but nowadays isn't just
many apps faster than actually just
including css files
because of all the performance work that
everybody's been doing since then and
that's
absolutely fantastic and it was really
important to push the whole community
towards focusing on performance and
making css interests much much more
performance
september of 2017 the call stack uh an
agency from poland released lunaria
which is a fantastic
js library that basically did the same
thing that astroturf did
where you can write your css in
javascript but then extract it to a css
file
but they actually made it work with the
style components api so if you want that
sort of output if you want to get a just
a css file afterwards
you can use the area and then write it
with the style components api
if you like that api and get a css file
out of it which is just fantastic and
again great library highly recommend
checking it out
november of 2015 emotion then released
version 10 of their library and
again i put emotion version 10 here but
the whole point wasn't the version 10
release because obviously i skipped over
nine versions so obviously not i'm not
showing all the versions here but the
important thing about emotion v10 is
that they really went and they invented
their own api called
the css pro and so suddenly you could
basically put a css property
on any html tag write your css in there
and it would just attach it as
a unique class name into the css address
thing which it turns out
is a really fantastic api it is a really
really really cool api that just feels
really nice to use
and they were the first ones to
popularize that um they weren't the
first ones to implement
it there were some libraries before them
that experimented with it but they
really popularized it and made it i
think that people really want it
and then in june of 2019 again my boss
brent jackson released themeui
which took this sort of css prop api
idea
and really honed in on making the
experience of writing
themeable component libraries the best
they could theme ui again
great library we use it basically for
all our stuff at gatsby it's an
absolutely
fantastic light we highly recommend
checking it out now
i just talked about i don't know two
dozen citizenship libraries
and something you might have noticed
while i was talking about them is that
i really like all of them
right all of them bring something unique
to the table and from the outside many
people think that this whole css and js
scene
is like a fist fight and we're all just
battling each other to the blood but
really
it's more like i
i sometimes say we we're like we
we collaborate by stealing from each
other right
everybody just steals like the best
ideas from everybody else
and that is actually fantastic because
it makes the entire ecosystem so much
better right
somebody comes up with a cool idea and
announces it and goes like hey
i tried this thing and it kind of works
what do you think everybody else goes oh
that doesn't sound like a too bad idea
what if we tried that what if we did
what if we put our own spin on it right
and really the whole the whole reason we
are where we are where so many people
using js and where css and js is really
i say in a biased opinion obviously
really great is because
we all collaborated with each other by
stealing from the best ideas from each
other right nobody went
oh this is my thing and [ __ ] everything
else right we all kind of went
what else could be cool about this what
could we make better right how could
this be better how
and we kind of collaborated and it was
it's a fantastic community and basically
all of the people i just mentioned are
really good friends of mine and i hang
out with them at conferences all the
time
they're absolutely fantastic people and
i love every single one of them
and that's really something you don't
see from the outside but
this whole community is just fantastic
now the question is
where the hell do we go from here what
is the future of css interest well the
answer is
i have no clue i really don't know
i spent the last five years in this
community i've
you know we made style components in
2016 and even before that i was thinking
about css and just
i've tried all the ideas i have right
i've literally tried if all the ideas i
had and then all the ideas that
everybody else had because we kept
stealing from them right
literally no ideas in my head
but here's the thing i'm sitting here
and i'm thinking you know
say 10 20 50 years down the line
do i think we're still going to be using
style components
i hope the [ __ ] not that would be sad
because we would have stagnated
right we would have stopped innovating
at that point right that would be really
sad to me i don't want that to happen
and so really what i want to get out of
this talk is i want to motivate you
to create the future of styling react
apps but also really any kind of website
um it's
much easier than you think right and if
you have any ideas if you have any
hunches if you have if you have a
feeling like
ah this could be easier how could we
make this easier start thinking about it
start tinkering
start building prototypes right share
them with the world and talk about them
and
discuss them and maybe it turns out that
your idea
is really nice like many of the ideas
that i just talked about right
for many of these ideas when when they
were announced nobody knew whether they
were nice nobody knew whether people
would like them nobody know knew whether
they even liked them
right or most of them were prototypes
that somebody threw together in like two
days and
just thought maybe this could work right
and for some ideas it turns out they
were absolutely horrible like doing css
and just by inline styles right some
ideas just turned out to be horrible
they're not good ideas which we know in
hindsight
but then other ideas actually turn out
to be really nice like this weird ipi
that glenn and i came up for
with first style components nobody seen
anything like that before right
nobody knew that whether or not that was
nice we just thought we just
you know announced that components we
were like try it and let us know what
you think and it turns out it's actually
a really nice api to use to build apps
with
um did we know that beforehand hell no
we just tried to build a prototype
that we thought might be nice right
really that's it now
if you actually have an idea and if you
want to do this here are some tips
and these don't just apply to css and
chess libraries these really generally
apply to open source projects
and pretty much any kind of project the
first one is
to make it work make it right and then
make it fast
um i see many people when they release
open source libraries or
or products they try to make it perfect
first right they try to compete with for
example style components right they're
like oh
i have an idea for css and just library
but for anybody to use this
it has to be as perfect as style
components right
now here's the thing we've worked on
style components for whatever four years
now
four and a half years now there's been
hundreds if not thousands of
collaborators working on it right
you're never going to beat that level of
quality but it doesn't matter right what
matters is whether your idea is nice or
not
the first version we built of style
components was a horrible hack
we basically took post css we ripped out
all of the node stuff
and we shipped that in the browser which
is the most bonkers thing anybody could
ever do that is not a good idea
but we just wanted to make it work we
just wanted to see we have this hunch
that that might be a nice thing to do
is that this api the style.div api might
be nice to use
we don't actually know if that's the
case but we're also never going to find
out if we don't make it work
and try it right and so we made it work
and then we shared it and we talked
about it and we got the feedback
then we took whatever feedback we got
and we made the library better we made
it right
right we people kept asking us how do i
add global styles people kept asking us
why can i adjust why can't i adjust my
global stars dynamically
people kept asking us all these
questions and we were like uh
yeah i guess you can't i guess we got to
build something to support that
right and so the api is only as good as
it is now because we got so much
feedback and because we incorporated
that feedback into our library because
we
sort of started covering all of the edge
cases and all the stuff that people
wanted
but that didn't that didn't happen at
the very beginning right we just made it
work at first and then we made it right
and then eventually
we made it fast right once we had apis
that we thought were
well-rounded that sort of covered all of
the use cases that's when we actually
got to work on making the library as
performant as it could be
um had we done that before then we would
have wasted so much work
because we would have made apis fast
that turned out to be completely wrong
right that turned out to be really bad
ideas because we had those as well right
not everything in style components was
an instant banger it just worked out the
books right
sort of some core ideas turned out to be
really nice but some others were
complete crap
and we wouldn't have known that before
getting all that feedback and making the
apis right
and that actually ties into my second
point share early and share often
right if you don't talk about your thing
if you don't share it with people
you're never going to get feedback and
without feedback you're never going to
make your library right
now that doesn't have to be external you
can also do this if you work at a big
company
you can also do this internally and
share it with people and talk to them
about it and get the feedback
but really nothing rivals the power of
open source where you can post your code
on github and literally get
thousands hundreds or thousands of eyes
on it pretty much pretty quickly
and get all that feedback going in of
course there's gonna be bad feedback
like
oh i think this is the worst idea ever
you're an idiot right that happens
that's happened to me like literally
millions of times whenever i talk about
css and judge somebody afterwards comes
up to me and it's like
yeah that was a good talk but [ __ ]
you're an idiot right
literally all the time happens so
frequently it's it's kind of funny to be
honest
um that's gonna happen and that's fine
and i don't really care about it
um but if i don't if we didn't share
style components that early and that
often and we didn't talk about the ideas
we had
we would have never figured out whether
this was nice and we would have never
been able to make our apis right sharing
is really really important
and actually if you end up experimenting
with css and js
just send me a dm on twitter send me a
dm tell me what you built and i'm going
to share with my audience because what
do i have an audience for if not for
that
right and i'm going to get you that
feedback to make sure to figure out
whether
your ideas are good ideas or not right
because i don't know
and you don't know but all of the world
might know and then thirdly and really
importantly document
all of the things a for the start for
the first style components release
we spent maybe like 20 of our time on
actually creating the library
and then we spent another 80 documenting
every single thing you could do with it
and how it worked and why it worked and
all of that stuff
and that was really vital to its success
if we hadn't documented
all the things nobody would have used it
because i i sometimes see this stroke
about open source that people go oh
if you want to figure out how this works
just read the source code but what the
[ __ ] is that like
nobody's going to read source code right
literally nobody does that i have never
done it and i don't think many other
people do i mean i do research
sometimes but not to figure out the api
if i want to use something just tell me
how to use it tell me what it can do
tell me all the edge cases tell me
everything you can't do
just tell me right document all the
things
that's really all i have for you today
like i said thank you for having me i
hope you enjoyed this talk and i look
forward to
all of your questions